let's talk about one of the first symptoms that
can occur if you're low in salt in your body
which this is actually very very common it's
weakness okay overall feeling of weakness
you're kind of tired let's talk about why first
of all the the root word salad is a latin word
for salted greens okay because the romans used
to dip their lettuce in salt which is interesting
the word salary or sale sal is the latin word for
salt and the romans sometimes used to get paid in
salt instead of money which is another interesting
point you should never consume refined salt always
is sea salt that's unpolluted himalayan salt is
great there's many other salts that are just as
good because the refined salt is just sodium
chloride and you're not getting all the other
minerals in the right balance that you need plus
to add aluminum which is not good salt is also
needed to make hydrochloric acid in your body
to help digest protein to help absorb minerals
to help kill pathogens and many people are low
in hcl and then they start getting acid reflux
indigestion bloating especially as you get older
an average person as a very minimum needs one
teaspoon of sea salt every single day but in many
cases they need more especially if they exercise
or do the ketogenic diet now i think the worst
scenario a person can be in is if they're
on a low salt diet and they're drinking lots of
water so they're diluting that little bit of salt
that they have and then they get on a diuretic
which will then cause the water to come out but
also the sodium too making them very deficient
in sodium and if they're on a high carb diet
with all those other factors what's going to
happen is they're going to retain the fluid in
the sodium but in the wrong places so they're
going to be in a real bad situation so you're
generally just going to have this feeling of
weakness and tiredness and then when you consume
some salt you're going to feel a lot better right
away so if you're endowed or confused about this
just add a little more salt to the diet and see
if your energy doesn't just perk up when i take
my electrolyte powder which has a lot of sodium
i always add more salt to it especially if you're
going on keto and you're no longer consuming all
these refined carbs with all this extra sodium but
if someone's just starting keto and they're
they've been on a high sodium refined diet
then they don't need to do that because they
already have too much sodium from things like the
monosodium glutamate and the extra sodium that
they put in a lot of junk foods but here's why
you get energy from sodium okay number one sodium
excites the heart muscle so without enough sodium
the heart can't pump and so you don't get enough
oxygen to the cells you don't get enough nutrition
you're going to feel tired and weak and
just as a side note when i talk about sodium
i'm really recommending sea salt because
you wouldn't necessarily want to take sodium
as an individual mineral because sodium
works with so many other things so
you want to get your sodium from sea
salt now sodium also regulates calcium
calcium homeostasis so without sodium
calcium can't really work in the body
so then you don't get the contraction of the
muscles you don't get the rhythm of the heart
and you can't produce the energy that you need
okay so that relationship is very very important
also sodium is involved in this really key pump in
the cells that produce voltage because the cell is
like a battery so you need sodium for that pump
you also need potassium as well and so if you're
low in sodium you're going to have low voltage
okay in the body and here's another interesting
thing about sodium sodium is very important
it's vital in making energy in the mitochondria
in your kidneys you have the most concentrated
mitochondria okay simply because sodium is so
important that the kidney has to maintain a very
high level of energy to recycle sodium and so this
is just another reason why the body considers
sodium as something that is very very important
and last point sea water the chemistry of seawater
is virtually identical to the watery portion
of your blood so when you consume more sea
salt you're fortifying your blood hey before
you go real quick i have a course entitled how to
bulletproof your immune system it's a free course
i want you to take it and here's why here's you
here is your environment everyone is focused on
this over here avoiding your environment but
what about here what about strengthening your
immune system that's what's missing this course
will show you how to bulletproof yourself and so
you can tolerate and resist your environment
much better by strengthening your own immune
system i put a link down in the description right
down below check it out and get signed up today